so many felt the vaccine was presented
as a cure that wouldn't require regular
booster shots
was that something you believed early on
did you always believed that many
regular shots would be required it may
be in a bigger picture how many
do you think this will
for the Pfizer vaccine is it something
you see that's taking a booster shot
regularly like annually
yes in the beginning when we had the
first months with the vaccine people
would ask me do we need another one and
I said we don't know I was very clear
about it then around April May I start
seeing the first data and I made
statements that I think we will need a
booster around 8 to 12 months after the
second dose and then after that annually
vaccinations this is what I said believe
is the one of the most likely scenarios
and it was based on the data that I had
but then Delta came
and because I always making the the
caveat that with apps and a new variant
with everything we know with Delta it
was proven that we need the booster to
move to the three to the six months and
this is what happened and I still said I
think the booster is a six months and
then I think will be an annual
revaccination likely we have to monitor
to see the data but this is the likely
scenario now we have omega
and the Omicron says that uh two doses
might be challenging we don't know
exactly yet but three doses work so
clearly a lot of countries already
started moving now the third dose not in
six from six months to three
so that they will reduce the period that
people will not be protected with uh
with uh the third dose uh I don't know
with Omicron if how long
this will last and frankly I don't know
if we will need a new vaccine
tailor-made to Omicron based on
everything we know so far we are
monitoring and you will know way more in
the weeks to come if there is a need for
a new vaccine we will have it
and if there is a need for mass
production of this new vaccine I can
also feel very comfortable that we will
not lose any of our capacity that we
have developed right now we are running
at 1 billion almost approximately
doses per quarter four per year and if
you have two streets and have half of
that in the new half of that in the old
we will do still 4 billion dollars so I
think the world should feel very very
comfortable but if there is a need we
will be ahead of the virus